Brian Scalabrine covers the Celtics for
NBC Sports Boston also worse for Yahoo
Sports and NBA radio on Sirius XM and
Brian set to join us now Brian good
morning how are you I'm doing well how
you guys doing
late who's calling you know I was I
thought I was waiting for a call from
you so I usually silence my phone but it
came on the home number instead but no
I'm all set I'm good if I told you back
in November that Boston would be here
now in the second round against the
76ers what would you have said Wow I
think that I thought that Boston would
be in a second round Philadelphia I
thought this would be a learning curve
for them and it was probably looking it
was like it was headed that way until
they grabbed ilya silva and Belinelli
added the shooting to the lineup I was a
huge huge fan of Ben Simmons from the
very first preseason game I watched him
play thought he was dynamic love the way
that he could finish around the basket
left hand right hand love it love the
fact that he could see over the defense
and he was a big-time passer so I could
see that happy I just didn't think the
rest of those guys were gonna be good
enough guys I missed out on Sarich he's
much better than I thought and in no way
because I have predicted that editions
of grabbing you know some some proper
premium shooters and in the in the
league and really of giving up nothing
to get them you know I thought folks
would be a little bit better than he is
but uh Philadelphia has definitely fast
forward the track of the rebuilding
process in wool and pretty much one
season how do you explain Boston
roughing up filling last night man
there's no explanation for it when it
comes to the Celtics and Brad Stevens
you think you know you think you could
say after a grueling seven-game series
and you sort of watch you know the
Houston Utah series and you tell look
flat like they had no no gas and you're
like man how are these guys going to
pull this off you got you got a
Philadelphia who is playing at an
all-time level you're like there's how
to see them in the NBA they need their
offense in the second half has been
tremendous in the playoffs there's no
explanation for the way that these guys
could come in and and win Game one
so handily like they did but this holds
I've said it with this team I've been
completely surprised when you count them
out they somehow find a way Gordon
Hayward Goes Down and you think man the
season's over Kyrie is having the
surgery he's out for the playoffs like
oh man they're trying to get out of the
first round
so with these guys they find a different
way I think at the end of the day the
coaching staff for the Celtics including
Brad Stevens and Danny Haines are on the
same page and that's why they're getting
what you're getting out of Jason Tatum a
rookie or guy like Terry Rozier in game
seven and Game one but you're also
getting guys to get minutes sooner than
we thought because of the injury to
Gordon Hayward and now with Kyrie out
and it I think it's benefited this team
that you had guys who got more minutes
and got more shots in big-time moments
then you probably thought they were
gonna get this season and it's paying
off now at least it has so far in the
playoffs yeah no question about it you
if you were had a pen and paper you want
to write down you know first option all
the way down like Rozier and Tatum 6/7
option when the start of this season
happened and now they're like to go to
guys so experience definitely helps now
if you project forward and you look at
the Celtics and who's to say like I
don't know how this thing is gonna
unfold in Toronto and Cleveland but
who's to say that they can't continue to
make this run without Kyrie without
Gordon Hayward but I really think when
you just sort of like take one step back
and when the season is over whenever
that does happen the Celtics got to be
so the legitimate top favorite in the
Eastern Conference to go to the finals
because of all the experience and you
can never predict injuries or anything
like that but man this team is
absolutely loaded with the development
of the Jalen Brown Jason Tatum Terry
Rozier on this team Brian Scalabrine
covers the Celtics for NBC Sports Boston
joining us Dan Patrick show who gave you
the nickname white Mamba Thank You King
yes there was you know Kobe came out
with his jump over the car commercial
was great like the Black Mamba campaign
and you know I've always worn Kobe shoes
because they're like I think they're the
best shoes that Knight he's ever made
and so I made a pair this whole thing
they was like the hop like whatever Kobe
did I did the opposite they were they
were his were black microlight it's like
the whole the whole nine
slapped him down on the table on the
team plane and I said these are the
white Mambo 1.0 they're basic eight
announced it and there was like t-shirts
outside of the United Center like within
a week and it was I mean the white mom
book craze took off but it's mostly
because of Stacey came
Jimmer talked to Colby about this yeah
yeah it's like not long conversations
but he does respect the parody on his
name but uh you know like I I'm not one
of these guys are gonna you know like
the white mob but it has a completely
different mindset in the black mamba
we're definitely from the same mama
family and we definitely like to take
his big fourth quarter shots with the
crowd on their feet
mmm I just happen to be up by 20 this
time when it's happening and Kobe is
usually in a one-point ballgame what's
the best performance you ever witnessed
either a teammate or playing against
somebody
I think it was Paul Pierce's 40 46 and a
half and overtime when I was I think I
was a rookie and I went in this way I
was not on his team I was on the New
Jersey Nets and it was Paul Pierce sis
and Paul Pierce at and he came out he
was like 1 for 8 at halftime he had two
points and I feel like what's all this
hoopla
what is this and he goes off 40 60 B
basically fouls out everybody on our
team and I'm like looking at the depth
chart thinking oh man if one more guy
goes out I'm gonna have to deal with
this right now watch those problems oh I
think that like like open my mind up
like before how did will score 100 in a
game like the idea that Paul scored 46
in a half and overtime it I kind of like
changed my whole perspective of saying
man maybe that is really possible but it
was it was a tremendous performance
nowadays it's like it's very different
with the three-point shot I mean Paul
did it but he did it like almost so hard
we made a couple threes along the way
but a lot of mid posts a lot of go into
the basket I think with 18 free throws
along the way so very very different
type of performance and what we see
nowadays from like a Steph Curry but
impressive as when you watch it who is
most likely to have a chance to go after
Kobe's 81
all in today's games you know I think
the game is so different now we don't
besides their calves and LeBron you
don't see as much isolation basketball
as you've done as you've seen in the
past the idea in the 2000s was give the
ball to your best player let them make
plays and if they're having a nice night
you keep milking that and everyone that
kind of stands around it's almost very
similar to the way the Cavs play now but
the New Age basketball is gonna be
motion offense and you know like cuts
and bad back screens and stuff like that
so maybe I could throw in maybe
Westbrook in that category they run a
lot of heavy isolation barrier on the
high pick-and-roll James Arnold yeah
hard would be another one but you can
euston spreads the ball out harden is a
tremendous passer so maybe like guys
like that but uh you know I think that
we will start seeing even more of a
shift in my guys the biggest problem I
made as analysts over the last five
years it's not understanding how fast
the game is changing from what it was
like III get it like from 1980s 90s
2000s to what it's becoming and wewe see
like stretch fives and the [ __ ] Center
shooting three-pointers it's happening
and it's happening really fast and if
you're not on board with that you're
gonna get a lot of players wrong along
the way Reggie Miller was on yesterday
and we started talking about you know
Kyrie Irving
you know Kawhi Leonard Jimmy Butler klay
Thompson we were actually started
talking about klay Thompson because he
probably has the best-looking jump shot
in the NBA and then we were wondering
how did he slip - I think 13th in the
draft or where 11th wherever it was and
then I said to Reggie Miller about
redrafting that draft so here's the
question - Reggie Miller and his answer
and then I'll get your response if we
read rap I got quiet agree we'll always
be one okay this I like Kyrie is oh is
always one then Kawhi I'm going I'm
going
Kyrie Jimmy Butler Wow
Klay quiet just for the simple fact I
need to know where Kwas head is what do
you think that's like that's a little
bit of overreaction don't you think yes
I do okay
I'm not like I'm not on me I'm gonna I'm
not on the media that I'm gonna stand up
for quite Leonard don't get me wrong dan
I think what he did this year was
inexcusable like be around your team
once you know you're not coming back and
you're not playing what's the point of
being in New York doing all the rehab
there just say hey man you can go to
write for a month do no rehab and start
this process all over again your body
where he will heal so I think you should
have been with his team the idea that
Tony Parker did you know we called them
out or pop sort of like the way that he
kind of called them out I think that cry
was in the wrong but I'm not gonna say
cry lizard I'm not gonna overreact and
see that quiet Leonard is not the best
player in that draft the guy's like
unbelievable two-way player okay so you
would you would take Kawhi one and then
yeah and then who's to you're probably
what Kyrie or just the names that they
mention man on the trap up top my head
well you have the Kyrie you have klay
Thompson Jimmy Butler yes I would go I
would probably put clay ahead of Jimmy
Butler and then but it's all it's all
like situational clay is a great second
and third option that's not it I don't
actually I'm not saying that would
disrespect to a guy who's not a number
one sometimes it's more important to
have those second so the second to you
guys like clay that are two-way players
that just make shots for you so but
Jimmy Butler yeah I mean I've probably
be fourth so I would go cry
Kyrie clay and then Jimmy if how
surprised would you be that Houston
comes out of the West and as opposed to
gonna be shot let me not like Dan I
always say it like this I like the media
looks like the new sexy pic right but if
Kevin Durant was on Toronto Boston even
maybe Milwaukee Philly that team would
be a surefire trip to the NBA Finals no
question about it
if Kevin Durant was on Houston they them
to be a surefire but why when they put
him on the Golden State Warriors who
happened to be unbelievable already how
come it's not like a shoo-in to go to
the NBA final it's like people searching
for like them to be the first one to
pick something different I like Houston
I think they're good
I think the Warriors when they are
locked in there on a level that the rest
of the NBA cannot cannot touch and it
really has I think it all has to do with
Kevin Durant he is an anomaly out there
he's off the ball he cuts he passes he
could shoot you can give him the ball he
can make plays all the attentions I love
Steph Curry I think he's phenomenal but
Kevin Durant is a matchup nightmare and
defensively he brings it and he can test
shots at the rim there's really nothing
you can do with his versatility I just
think like there's no answer for him
like if if they didn't have him if they
go to the finals and they don't have him
and LeBron somehow gets there like
LeBron becomes the favorite in the
finals if they don't if the Warriors
don't have Kevin Durant that's how
important Kevin Durant is if you're a
coach and you're preparing for him good
luck with that who's more unstoppable
Durant or Harden has a one-on-one player
and harden as a team guy like in the
warrior system its Durant like Durant
off the ball movement incredible his
back cutting is incredible
his ability to pass and shoot off the
bounce is incredible but harden is I
know there's like a like probably caused
controversy here but harden to me is the
greatest one-on-one player we have ever
seen I had guy who can shoot off the
dribble like that is insane wait wait
wait wait hold on
say that again just so we will be
recording on Brian Scalabrine here three
two one James Harden is the best
one-on-one player I have ever seen
because of his ability to shoot the
three off the dribble like a lot of
credit to Kobe and Michael for what they
did in the mid block area or their
isolation but just a simple fact that
you have to guard him up the floor he's
an impossible cover it's like it's
insane that he's a head of the NBA like
the way to everybody in the NBA is
playing the same game and he is like
head and shoulders above him on the
offensive end you gotta warn us before
you drop in hot takes on us there mama
yeah I think so Stevie Nate did that
like a two months ago and I don't think
I don't think it is a hot day no daryl
morey
Steve and egg kind of countered him know
like you just looked at one on one when
you watch him play Holi how he does what
he does is mind-boggling what's called
traveling off the dribble three stuff
like if you took MBA players and you
said shoot the James Harden step-back
three against zero defenders I don't
know how many guys there's like do you
guys like Damian Lillard seth Curry and
probably missing a few that could really
make that shot
but James Harden does he consistently he
to be inside the three and step back
behind the three and shoots a three at
that level right over a guy it's insane
I don't think I've ever seen anything
like that and and guys when they're
gardening I mean that's they're at his
mercy well you tried to guard LeBron
right you know what that feelings like
LeBron zone stop avoiding it different
he's like a different type of
unstoppable right he just goes to the
basket and he bowls you over are you
really afraid of him shooting the three
off the dribble like that
if he's let's say if LeBron shot like
James Harden like there would be no
question yeah yeah no lucky that it's
like LeBron takes a few shots you know
on his own like just jacked up some
threes and some nice he doesn't have in
sometimes he does so yeah yeah a little
bun is great don't get me wrong I'm not
like trying to see here and say he's not
I just I just have never seen anything
like to what James Harden is able to do
and in his ability to finish out the
basket add to the fact that he can pass
when he finally gets there and those
those lobs I don't understand why we
don't do more backflips over James
Harden this year like when Russell
Westbrook averaged a triple-double
LeBron James we talked about how it's oh
my god this guy's so great he needs no
rest but man what is what about James
Harden can we give him some credit for
what he's done people he'd see that we
have never seen before he's going to be
the MVP so he's gonna get love are you
saying is harden the best player on the
planet no it's like the best offensive
player in it okay yeah the best player
on the planet is who
I guess you got to say LeBron I guess I
think it's Kevin Durant but a lot of
people think it's LeBron James so I just
go with thee like the general take that
everyone thinks he's the best player on
the planet I don't know their offensive
rating is not great sometimes a
defensive rating Kevin Durant seems like
a beast but if Kevin Durant was in
LeBron situations I think we probably I
mean it would be tough for anybody to
have success in that and with Cleveland
right now what the Cavs be better with
Kevin Durant is that okay like they
played completely different like the way
that the Cavs play that isolation with
LeBron I don't like the system I don't
like the way that they play but maybe
there's no other way to do it when you
have LeBron James on your team but you
know like I think more Kevin I think
Kevin Durant's more of a matchup
nightmare I think James Harden in a way
is probably more of a matchup nightmare
then LeBron just going at the top of the
key isolation so how about LeBron if he
played with Golden State I don't know
work as well I mean may I mean it would
be very it would be very different I
like I love the fact that KD has scored
all the different ways on the ball off
the ball cutting shooting you know I'll
pick and roll like that I love that
about he's like exactly what they need
when like the motion offense isn't
working so I don't know if LeBron was on
that team if it would be as Domino's it
is yeah I guess you would probably
assume that he would have the ball in
his hands and you would just spot a step
hurry and you spot up well he'd be
driving addition he'd be he averaged 15
assists are you sure oh my goodness he
would power guys off the dribble go to
the hoop and dish out to klay Thompson
klay Thompson would have to take a
dribble the entire season
you know Steph Curry there even draymond
Green so you think they would be better
with LeBron James Kevin Durant they
would be different but I think
eventually they would be better
like I love Durant and he's starting to
prove he can be a two-way player and his
defense is underrated but you know
LeBron is passing in a pass happy
offense like that I just I can't imagine
that he wouldn't make them
better because Duran is just adds to
what they already have
LeBron gives you something different he
can post up he can drive and dish I'm so
I think maybe but maybe adding to what
they already have is exactly what they
need and maybe reinventing the wheel is
not what makes us the Golden State
Warriors go let's just assume let's say
that all they did was stand around and
wait for LeBron to driving kick to them
maybe they wouldn't be as effective the
idea of being a willing passer off the
ball not necessarily a willing passer to
get assists but just to move it just to
move it like that so that's important
too you know like I think that and what
about the fact that when you know guys
drives you don't have to respect LeBron
jumpers as much as they have to respect
Kevin Durant but they have to respect
the drive more than they do Durant's
Drive sure like would you say that I was
going with your theory then Ben Simmons
if Ben Simmons was on the Warriors doing
the same thing that LeBron would be
doing would you say that Ben Simmons
would be better than Durant no guy who
just gets downhill anytime he wants
nobody no you don't you don't respect
his shot at all LeBron had look at
LeBrons numbers from three I mean he's
got a respectable jumper from three
mid-range jumper yeah Ben Simmons you're
not respecting the jumper so it's
completely down yeah I'm definitely not
respecting LeBron jumper like you
Arkady's well no Katie's got one of the
greatest of all time yeah we've had
enough hot takes here Brian
all right oh you did machine kind of hot
takes over here jeez yeah that's what we
do here Brian
reacting because I always I always want
to know your stance and by the way I
love this show I actually watch your
show on subtitles that while we're not
you don't have to apologize for watching
the show and to an exam I know I'm not
watching it like live like sitting there
watching TV I I'm doing it during my
workouts but with that being said
without overreacting again gun that's
Billy Boston I'm still like really the
Cavs were land for a Toronto series I'm
still gonna take Cleveland begrudgingly
because I just don't know if Toronto
knows how to beat LeBron and they got to
prove they can the this series says is
much about Toronto as it does Cleveland
because if Toronto does not be Cleveland
then I
you got to start looking at dismantling
that and Cleveland if they happen to
lose then I think you know LeBron says
you know see you but so I think it says
a whole lot about both teams there but
I'm gonna go begrudgingly Cleveland and
I like the 76 are still I think that the
Celtics are doing it with momentum and
the sum of the parts there but I do
think the overall talent of Philadelphia
will win out here gotcha let me give me
back on air after Toronto beats the Cavs
please oh all right just tell Todd when
Toronto beats the gas just tell Todd to
text me and we'll get back on air I like
to know why when when they do lose I'd
like to know your take on LeBron and the
Cavs and what's gonna happen okay all
right well thank you that's nice Brian
Scalabrine use the white mamba for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]